foreign
versus men's pay that is something
that's been talked about for years
indeed it has and there are new numbers
out there that we found overnight that
the gender pay Gap has not changed much
in two decades yes that's because women
are still not doing manual labor jobs
and the problem was under the gender pay
Gap what they do is they take the
average salary of a man and the average
salary of a woman and they don't they
don't make it by job like you know they
don't break it down by a job they just
do the total and the problem is since
men are like offshore Drillers and women
aren't
and also because you know men uh you
know go to work yeah
well that's it okay that's true um you
know it turns out no it's true women
look it is it is absolutely a fact that
a men negotiate harder for money yes B
women uh when they ask for things they
tend to ask for quality of life work
life balance things instead of more
money like women are like oh man an
extra week vacation and some PTO that's
what I'm talking about and men are like
I don't care how much do I make and how
much can I make like what's the ceiling
what I can make that's all men care
about and then whether in sales and [__]
a lot of men getting sales car sales and
trucks they're like I don't want to
limit I'll stay here all [__] day and
night I hate my wife and then what I
mean like that's how men are built and
then women get pregnant take a job the
boss isn't allowed to ask if they're
pregnant and as soon as they're hired
they take three months off to have a
have a kid
dude when I worked in sales do you know
how often I saw that it was ridiculous
it's a real building they worked there
for a couple months and he's like oh I'm
pregnant especially when we live near
the Marine base and it was just like
every time [__] Jody
so let's see what they're saying
research numbers show women in the US
are not expected to achieve equal pay
until the year
2059. we're gonna look at the numbers
across the world according to the Gates
Foundation it's predictable according to
what Foundation
what Foundation was that
um
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation oh
okay all right cool is that the vaccine
block out the sun company yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know the guy that
made an operating system that's
basically just stolen spyware now
you know that guy yeah okay cool yeah he
also decides how much people make in the
planet and he owns most of the farmland
in completion sense
uh Sinister yeah but he also wants less
people on the planet too so that all
that sounds more Sinister right by any
means necessary where he was you know
you know messing around about maybe
getting sterilizing people and with what
okay this isn't getting any lesser no no
no no no I know I know but hear me out
though
huh new Gears of work coming out
Microsoft what do you think that's
pretty tight okay first off I just hope
it works on release you know I mean I
don't want to have to [__] you know
wait for the patch and I hear what
you're saying but there's a new Halo
coming out I need to finish the fight I
need to finish the fight you know I
can't sit here worrying about if we're
gonna have food or if they're
sterilizing us with some sort of Agents
I can't do that you can't do that or if
they're gonna order the blacks to burn
down the AutoZone again I don't know let
me know now because I need to get
headlight bulbs and by the way Microsoft
bought Bethesda so when the new Fallout
comes out the new Skyrim comes out what
am I gonna do what do you think I'm
gonna do I'm gonna play Elden ring not
another rings I'm going to spell their
Scrolls that's what I'm going to be
doing
well you guys are out there worrying if
we're gonna have a future all right I'm
going to be hopping up and down or
sneaking around just to like spam the
sneak at the beginning so it's set up
for the rest of the game yeah while you
lose is just too worried uh wondering
who's gonna gang rape you to death the
Russians and the Chinese I'm gonna be
playing a game that's totally broken on
a day but don't worry two years later
thanks to the commodity Community
they'll fix it boom ah Who's laughing
now you know that's the worst part of
Elder Scrolls in Fallout games it's like
everyone's like oh my God the wait till
it gets released and I'm like yeah how
do you think I feel I always wait until
two years after it's out so you should
see happening a broken mess yeah like I
don't get a game writer without
especially not a Bethesda game I'm
always like nah wait a year or so and
once there's The Unofficial patch I'll
play it I was just about to make
official patch I'm like I'm in every
[__] Bethesda game the UNIF the
official unofficial patch which which
they oftentimes end up including in
later releases they do they they either
buy they either buy the program or out
or maybe at least they pay the guys
they're monitor right wait what no
you're getting paid a king of all pixel
support Royce hype train coming through
don't be embarrassed addiction is a
disease and nothing to be ashamed of
that's me what happens bro
according to the gates does it make you
a bad person Foundation it's predicting
completion dates for Equal Pay globally
22.77 okay but see the problem when you
do go globally now you're going to ask a
bunch of African countries and Middle
Eastern countries to pay women the same
it's 250 years from now right yeah we're
unreal here well so this morning on this
International women's day we are
upholding women's achievements you're
going to go to North Korea and they're
going to go wait a minute pay women
no they're going to go to North Korea
they're going to go women
they're gonna know they're gonna go wait
pay people
but we'd also want to recognize
challenges like the general that's like
that Meme I was talking about remember
when uh they were like you know people
with a time machine or like oh no if you
could bring people back from the dead
and it was literally like uh George
Washington and he's like uh so no it was
somebody from the uh like the 1800s like
why are women voting and then it was
George Washington it was like why is
everyone uh why are you know
um whatever people vote and non-lander
when I was Voting and then the last one
was just uh Louis the 14th like why are
people voting
Benny with a nine dollar co-fi sorry I
missed a couple of these I forgot you
guys were donating there uh with five
dollars says Nick ricada got his channel
why did he even go look at this Nick
we're getting got his channel back hey
yo dance knot with one from a couple
days ago 50 five dollar hype train when
is merch gonna go do a woman's History
Month bit for our Queen Nasim
um
uh five Zen Rhino five dollar actual
factual hype training an effort Raya uh
in effect Ray apps great guy never met
him
all right let's uh keep on with the
international women whining [__] we
need to help us discuss some hard truths
while looking for Solutions
oh yeah you saw that that woman Plus
Award went to a dude again another
biological male won an award for women
joining us this morning Julie cam Julie
good morning thank you so much for
waking up bright and early what
why do Boomers always angle their
[__] webcam like that with us you
look fabulous
thank you good morning to you both so
Julia is a CEO of a jbk Associates
International Grigio the person
[Laughter]
Live Laugh Love is in at least three
places in that woman's home Garen
[__] teed she has a Peloton
collecting dust that has her bras
hanging on it somewhere you want to
[__] bet
you know here in South Florida she's got
four tattoos but they're only black
they're only like the line tattoos that
lesbian get yeah yeah
a woman a woman-owned firmware she is
the leader in Recruitment and Retention
so Julie we've looked at the numbers
globally and the U.S can you share with
us where Florida actually falls on the
track of closing that gender pay Gap
sure well actually Florida ranks 19th in
the states
um and basically if you look at well
yeah well tell women to be become
alligator handlers and [__] learn how
to drive cigarette boats because that's
the [__] skills you need in [__]
Florida okay if you're not gonna do that
I'm gonna cry to me okay hey can
somebody Google how many alligator
catchers they're female alligator
catchers are on the Everglades I'm
assuming it's not as many I got you hold
on two uh none none okay that would be
zip there was one got eaten by an
alligator
so you know not great the salty
engineered ten dollars Royce's recovery
after care fun stay strong bud
not there's one but it's just
Bubba's going through like a rough
divorce and I don't know man he's on
this [__] estrogen oh so the best
female alligator Hunters are [__] that
makes sense
sorry women men are just better certain
areas of Florida like Hollywood can you
uh can you tilt your head up just a
little bit we're not seeing enough of
your neck yeah no no really I want to I
want your neck and face look like one
straight line I want you to I want you
to look like [__] Beaker from them
from [__] Muppets can we start that
campaign to drive the wedge between
women and trans people even more we just
gotta start the Ever every great woman
started off as a man yes
I love that you know I'd be so good for
international women's month for example
they really have closed Caitlyn Jenner
can we get
um can we start kick it off come on Lena
mean somebody do this get one of those
things where each word is a picture like
each picture has a word that makes the
statement you know what I mean so it'll
be like every great woman started out a
man or whatever and just make like each
square a picture of a great trans woman
and just it's like we're starting on
make sure you say every great woman
started off as a dude
by the way king of all pixels told me to
point out that a Julie's middle name is
mine
her name is not Julie my struggle
[Laughter]
the Gap quite significantly in fact
women are actually earning more than
Julie short for Julia ah yes you're
right uh about almost five percent more
to be exact uh in this city of about 150
000 or so residents well let me let me
ask you something ma'am you know I'm bad
from me uh to all women out there if you
tried not being [__] losers
also you could go you women could become
men now become a man yes become a dude
dude hey ma'am you know you guys don't
even have to try hard like to be think
about it like you just have to put a
ball cap on and just start being like
hey what's up bro just act like that
[__] from Just One of the guys women
you get what you deserve you were the
Allies to trans people and because of
that gender means nothing so you can't
argue about a gender pay Gap if gender
doesn't exist there is no gender pay gap
between the 36 genders there's a pay Gap
see that's the [__] problem women a
lot of you [__] live in this [__]
hell that you created this hell for
yourself you became allies because they
just want to get married and they were
like oh they just want to cut their
dicks off it's fine like oh they just
want to take my job wait what was the
last one that's what happened if that's
it goes from that to like wait they want
to take my job
that's the issue you [__] played
yourself
and it's funny here we are
and it's funny for me it's funny for me
you know actually earning more than 40
you know about 47 500 which is actually
up that's nice ma'am did you take into
consideration of the discrepancies that
might be brought forth by the fact that
literally not a single waitress on this
[__] planet reports or tips also by
the way hold on hold on guys looking at
what's on the screen now I could tell a
woman did the numbers for this read
number two
uh
we're actually uh pretty good I came out
of Puerto Rico Florida ranks 19th out of
51 states
[Music]
I mean look I know they mean porn I look
I know they mean Puerto Rico right I
understand I really push him for that
statehood I know they mean Puerto Rico
right I know they mean that right Puerto
Rico oh Puerto Rico oh I actually took
me a second year at 51 state that's uh
that's how you know women did it did the
math
they can't argue about how you're not
getting saved enough and then say [__]
like 51 steaks
that's why you're not getting beaten up
you dumb idiots
so you know there's not one guy on the
team like that um
technically
instead of giving you one tool
as soon as the guy says something hey
guys stop man explaining to me don't man
explain I got it it's International
women's day they said well all women
were going to do this report okay
almost 33 percent uh from 2017 uh to
2021. I like the fact that the women are
young women are out hurting young men in
Gainesville that's because they're all
working at the coconut Cabaret
let's be honest
that's a good point
what's what's the name of the huge strip
club right before Gainesville
um Cafe risque Cafe risque they all
working Cafe risque
the [__] claim to fame dude guys to
tell you how classy Cafe risque is the
claims of Fame off to all the Billboards
when you drive by this trucker showers
that's a good it's not even a strip club
though there's no booze or anything no
there's well there's it's literally a
diner I'm not kidding it's just a strip
club Diner example young women are
actually out earning younger men so the
State of Florida are making some
significant gains low-key I'm going to
read it in the way I think he means it
the year is 20 20
2276 and Puerto Rico still hasn't
achieved gender pay equality no but
listen to this [__] reveal what she
truly feels too because she goes well in
Gainesville women are now earning more
than men so we're making progress so
this isn't about equality you want more
than us of course they want more [__]
look at the this female soccer players
got what they wanted the men are
subsidizing the men had to take a picket
to pay them more even though men make
more because nobody wants to watch
women's sports
except for like volleyball and that's
just a jerk off why are women like this
you remember the time that the American
soccer team got beat by a junior varsity
[__] 15 year olds bro by 15 year old
students one of my favorite stories bro
and it was like it was like three to one
ball to the you know to the rest of the
country so there is progress I mean
which is which is really encouraging it
lends itself to a little bit of
confidence so we did a lot of research
here and and we found some numbers that
one study shows narrowing the wage Gap
could actually boost the worldwide
economy by you know what will help all
these young men that feel
disenfranchised are going to kill
themselves and then that'll balance it
out that'll fix the balance sheets how's
that sound huh
you know what hap you know what'll fix
this merch
CEOs male CEOs need to turn trans
think about it there we go we need more
you know what I'm starting the thing
right now we need more trans
billionaires
because all those men if they turn into
women
pay Gap done
no more Wars there you go make Elon Musk
trans I don't hate this think about it
[__] trans CEOs is how you fix the
pickup mathematically speaking to be
fair here it is trans he's just
transhumanist yeah no I know I get it
but I'm you know what I mean I'm these
guys gotta be turned to a girl you know
it wants to turn into a robot
well yeah maybe you like it if you had
robot ears he really is that dude from
Grandma's Boy that was obsessed with
like I'm gonna get robot legs put in
yeah exactly
how can you see
any male CEOs that are not turning trans
are part of the reason there's a gender
pay Gap so now balls in your court
seven trillion dollars so why is it
taking so long it seems like this would
lend itself to well some incentive
well I think we
think it's a little thing called covet
happens no no the covet didn't happen
the government's response to covet
happened there's a big difference
there's that and basically it set us
back hundreds of years in fact hundreds
of
this is how fragile women are just how
fragile women are according to her I
don't think she's right but women this
is how fragile this woman thinks you are
two years of Cove had set you guys back
a hundred years
I [__] wish it said it back 100 years
because then I could [__] beat him
they'd have to shut the [__] up and they
couldn't vote yeah because we said it
well no remember she said hundreds which
is even better no hold on Virgie be
careful let's make sure we do this right
when were showers and like heightened
tampons and stuff invented because I
want to go to an area it's a sweet spot
where they don't their [__] don't
smell and stuff you don't like smelly
[__] either so you got to pick like a
really good sweet spot like what's the
50s maybe 60s yeah we go back a hundred
years everybody's [__] bedroom is
gonna smell like the [__] bat cave
yeah yeah [__] Nookie Thompson only
Nookie Thompson and his [__] people
like him can take baths so yeah I'm not
you know
I don't know if I want to do Boardwalk
Empire times but I'm thinking like 50s
60s right
uh not Boardwalk Empire
so you still want 20. do you want
Boardwalk Empire free Boardwalk Empire
so but but but but but the hygiene
you know it does give you an excuse to
hose them down
I mean I guess I just feel like the
hygiene is worse and I think the farther
back you go the bushier the [__] is
going to be it's a whole like thing
I suppose but I mean you know at what
cost do you want to [__] have shaved
[__] and having them wearing [__]
Marc Jacobs daisy you know I mean is
that a thing you care about well I'm
just saying like
look they wanted to [__] beware
I literally just had a chick tell me her
perfume like a couple nights ago and it
stuck in my head so I'll make that right
it's just funny it was like it was just
that's what makes a joke I know that was
great it was no big job but like that's
you want to give them the right to vote
and let them drive and let them work and
let him be this like this insufferable
[__] on the news all at the cost of what
some Bush and they smell a little nicer
I'll take the trade off all right I mean
hey shut the [__] up now get out there
and turn some goddamn butter you can
Mouse right here folks merch likes musty
[__] yeah if they shut the [__] up
they leave me the [__] alone and shut up
yeah I love them silent musty [__] I
like that I like to think that new
people that are new women that are
tuning in on Rumble maybe this shows
this is on the front page or two tonight
or watching us and going live on the
show ladies you know what these guys got
a point
uh you know I mean what do you want
somebody maybe you go back in time to
Boardwalk Empire times maybe you invent
Bush shaving maybe you'll come up with
all the good ideas okay make millions
well hundreds back then but still you
could you'd make hundreds of dollars
which in today's Times is billions
that's a good point
I mean look I hear what you're saying
also Central AC is a big thing for me
it's gonna be really warm just women no
no no no no no we're staying right here
okay sorry the women Oh I thought this
is different hold on so the women are
gonna be like the 20s but we have modern
day conveniences they could shave their
[__]
then yeah fine yes I'm in that's fine
yeah but only if they ask nicely and if
we get our permission first yeah
obviously they need to ask for
permission or have some sort of voucher
system I'm with you there Virgie
obviously we can't just like we can't go
any other thing and they can share their
[__] whenever they feel like it yeah
no that's that leads to chaos and then
we're right back where we started yeah
no economy for women no
turns out we just invented time machines
so we could become the Jews before the
Jews no economy for women sounds like a
[__] sequel to No Country for Old Men
so lesbian telling you to pick friend oh
some lesbian with the same bull haircut
is flipping a coin holding a shotgun
uh the numbers actually show that 2
million women stepped aside out of the
workforce during covid as you can
understand they are the typical God
forbid they stepped aside and you know
started a family like God forbid that
happened right oh no call caregivers uh
they are the ones that were staying home
with the children as children were doing
remote learning and it was very
difficult I remember the caregivers
right then they build like the the
whatever it was spark something and then
oh no you're thinking of Halo again
you're thinking of Halo yeah no no no no
no no you think of the aliens no no no
no no no no no no I don't why don't the
caregivers pay women more well probably
something to do with the flood ah what
how much does the Covenant pay women if
I come in it doesn't pay women oh man
that sounds big they know exactly what
they're doing
very difficult to make up uh that that
uh that time that they have taken away
from the workforce so that really as I
did my research I found that that was
really a very significant aspect yeah
that was very very you know what it is
you know what this is right here
these two ladies are putting on a clinic
on why women make less money yeah
absolutely you because listening to you
talk socks watching you play sports
socks watching you do things sucks
there's a reason why I all like these
rich baller ass women are all like
Rachel Ray and all these other [__]
you know what I mean like the Martha
Stewart that's what we want to watch you
do crafts is that your phone yeah I'll
go it's in the other room sorry it's the
women it's the woman police the woman
police are calling her to take them out
I'm kidding no one respects female cops
they're gonna get our boy
you can [__] push them away one arm
ladies I'm really sorry it's
International women's day we're trying
to be as nice as we can and this is
probably it it's probably the best we
could do I don't know this is [__]
Monumental we love you ladies well you
know we're obviously we're kidding not
about the whole brain going back the 20s
and we're [__] serious about that
yeah but we didn't even get to the
beating part yeah we're kidding about
allowing you to shave we're not going to
we'll have you shaved